what about strength training and muscle
building or at least we had a discussion
about this so what do you believe is the
value of
um
of you know training outside of the
sport so fitness
lifting heavy lifting explosive
all kinds of lifting
do you believe personally for me i
believe and i've learned that from from
john
i used to to do like
to train like a bodybuilder before
because i thought in my early days of
competition that was
the most efficient way to do things to
because it was like i was watching
jean-claude van damme
arnold schwarzenegger we thought back
back in the day that was the thing
that that's how we should do it you know
for to get ready for a fight
but i realize
later on
uh
that it's all about efficiency
and some guys they don't lift at all and
they're doing pretty well so i
do cross training mostly for longevity
more it's mostly for the rapid rep
like a therapy it's more therapeutic
than for performance it's to keep my
body healthy to do a certain movement
that are different than what i do every
day in the gym in combat sport
to keep me
uh
healthy and and
athletic so all the interesting movement
stuff that you've done outside the sport
that was for
there
mostly the reputation i think it does it
could tran
transcend to performance but it's mostly
the republic i do not believe that
squatting
five plates or bench bench pressing
three plate will make me a better
fighter i do not i believe actually it
could hurt me more it could damage me
more than than benefit me
so
according to somebody who on instagram
posts
a lot of pictures of you being shredded
and huge
uh what's the value of strength so i do
like a combination of uh
john got us big into like gymnastics
type movements
like toes to bar and muscle ups and
things like that when we were young um
like toes to bar because that's like the
exact motion you have to do when you're
retaining guard it's knees to chest
so i do a lot of that stuff
in combination with i do a lot of
opposite of george i do a lot of
bodybuilding workouts
where i do like a basic split like a
chest and triceps back and biceps day
and my idea is that
weightlifting should always be a
supplement to jiu-jitsu so you shouldn't
be missing a jiu-jitsu session to lift
weights um so i don't do i do probably i
train jiu-jitsu every day and i lift
three to four times a week um i feel
like lifting seven days a week for me is
too much and the lifting takes a lot of
energy when you do like hard lifts like
that um but my idea is if you want to
get good at jiu jitsu do jiu jitsu and
if you want to be bigger and stronger
lift weights and uh and eat food and um
i i generally don't go super heavy when
i lift you start putting crazy weights
then start tearing muscles and stuff um
so i usually do moderate weights with a
with a very high rep rep range like four
sets of 20 with a drop set at the end to
fatigue the muscles break the fibers and
grow
okay so
forces are 20 that's interesting so
that's more for endurance and raw
strength yeah and also i think
closer to competition i'll pick the
intensity up and
while there's no real way to get
significant gains in vo2 max i think
that lifting and just getting used to
mentally redlining um gets me kind of in
competition shape because a lot of times
in jiu jitsu the guys i'm training with
they're not on a technical level
where they can
physically exhaust me to the point where
i feel like i'm gonna die
but uh i get most of that like when i'm
wrestling because i'm not as efficient
in wrestling so i get a lot more tired
and lifting when you do like if you do
like four sets of 20 leg press to squat
and you go back and forth like you're
like about to die at the end and
i think i feel like gets me in the
mental habit of redlining before
competition but does muscle help you
it's like the actual mass of muscle like
this so being stronger will always help
in a combination will always help yeah
to some degree it's not going to be
to a degree where
it overrides efficiency but i think that
it can't help being strong or can't hurt
being stronger well there's a bunch of
people who believe depending on the
sport that um
strength can quickly become uh
that have detrimental effects to
efficiency
yeah like
that certain kind
i mean if strength is purely is like
very cleanly purely applied to the exact
movements of the sport so in judo the
explosiveness you need is very difficult
to replicate in any kind of way except
by doing judo yeah i mean
for us uh you always have to understand
there's only so much technique that can
overcome a certain amount of strength
like if we all try to fight a silverback
gorilla it's gonna kill us
um but that that being said um i do
think that like for example heavyweights
are usually the least technical because
they rely on their size and strength to
beat smaller people
but i think that if you stay with us
with the discipline of doing everything
very precise and i train with a lot
smaller people most of the time so
i get out of the habit of using uh using
my strength um i think if you're very
precise with the way that you train i
think that the extra size and strength
can help you quick question how would
you fight a silverback gorilla
i mean is that what which animal do you
think you can actually defeat that would
be impressive that most people would say
you can't
you know i actually
i don't have an uh an answer to this i
thought you gotta say it i want i want i
want to say that me and john had like a
four hour discussion on this one time
i'm like what would win bear or gorilla
and he went like this whole dissertation
about how like jaguar spin underneath
and like baron bolo silver backs and
kill him and like rip their rip their
artery and their legs out it was amazing
i guess okay so before we talk about
strength john let me ask you what
do you think people would be surprised
by if two animals faced one of them
would win and people wouldn't predict
that so they would be surprised by the
effectiveness of certain animal at
fighting
in the whether it's in the forest in the
jungle so let's
slow down
so there's two animals of different
species fighting
and most people would pick
so for example the lion gets a lot of
credit for some reason i'm not exactly
sure why the king of the jungle
well
you know a lot of people told me that
the lion
for example the tiger can
be aligned yeah this is one of those
age-old debates
okay yeah well in grappling in fighting
it feels like some animals use
teeth
and some use
other parts of their body also like bear
actually i don't even know how they
they have extraordinarily powerful
and long claws and in addition they're
powerful biters as well so i wonder and
the same with the silverback
i don't know how much they're i love
that we're having this discussion
we need joe rogan for this discussion i
think so yeah i think so um
so
uh
your your question has gone in in about
five different so it started with
strength uh and let's go back there
which is
do you think for for an athlete and you
just let's let's stick to grappling
uh do you think strike strength is
helpful or detrimental uh i've always
believed that
two things
will
create whatever
whatever effectiveness you have in
grappling those are
your skill set and your attributes
and the best athletes are those who
excel in both
don't kid yourself if someone gets twice
as strong
by some kind of magic potion they're
going to be a more effective grappler if
someone gets
twice the level of endurance that they
had previously they will be a more
effective grappler these physical
attributes have a very important outcome
on the uh sorry a very important effect
upon the outcome of matches
um it's always a good thing to be
stronger it's always a good thing to
have better endurance it's always a good
thing to have better balance or whatever
other attribute you throw out there
gordon's point was okay everyone agrees
on that but there's a problem in order
to build these
things you have to carve into other
elements of your training regimen and
then it becomes which becomes more
important increases in strength or
increases in skill
there comes a point where investing in
strength training starts to get
diminishing returns
i can't tell the difference between
someone who bench presses 300 pounds on
the mat versus someone who bench presses
400 pounds but that's a big difference
that's a 100 pound difference and for an
athlete to go from bench pressing 300
pounds to border bounds that would
require a great deal of
of training effort and focus
but if i can't tell the difference when
i grapple and then why bother okay once
you get to a certain strength level
it doesn't really help that much to go
from a 400 pound bench press to a 450
pound bench press at that stage you're
really getting a diminishing returns on
your training investment
now skills on the other hand
experience far far less in terms of
diminishing returns every new skill
you develop
can translate
very very well into big increases in
performance look at the example of gary
tonan that we talked about earlier
investments in guillotine
made a significant improvement in his
effectiveness in matches and led
directly to some of his most important
victories
um but if he had invested the same
amount of training time and developing a
bench press that was 25 pounds more than
previously that would have had no
outcome no
influence on the outcome of those
matches
so the question always becomes yep
everyone acknowledges that these
physical
attributes are important and everyone
understands that becoming stronger or
fitter is a desirable thing and every
athlete should work on them the
interesting question becomes okay at
what point
do you start to say
i'm not going to be helped by further
increases
in in strength training or endurance
training
um
and my point with my athletes is in the
overwhelming majority of cases
if there's any kind of doubt invest more
heavily in skill training than attribute
training especially once you get to a
certain level on the attributes well the
interesting thing that i think you
should account for with strength
training
is um
there's instagram
there's the world
it's uh it seems to be more fun
to build muscle mass
it's like an addiction yeah people have
there's also economic elements too like
most people i i hate to say this but
it's true
most people are more concerned with
image
than function and
uh
it's hard to sell
a fighter or a jujitsu athlete who
doesn't look like one looks like fedor
yeah it's a tough sell now you can do it
in fighting and jujitsu because
ultimately it's about whose hand is
raised at the end of the match and you
could even use it as a selling point you
can be a guy that doesn't look like you
should be winning but he is winning that
is a selling point but if you give most
people a choice between
looking like arnold schwarzenegger and
winning matches versus looking like
fader and winning matches most people
will select i wish i'd rather look like
arnold schwarzenegger and so most
athletes feel almost like an economic
compulsion to be in good shape and in
order to advance their marketability
yeah nike's not gonna sponsor fedor or
tank abbott
yeah tank habit
no
fatal maybe
but yeah yeah
at the very top there's there's
something about uh aesthetic um
like image of strength and power it's
also an also a personal thing if you
look at yourself in the mirror do you
like what what you see you know what i
mean yeah do you find yourself
attractive you know what what can you do
to make you look better and i think to
me to me it was something one of the
reasons i work out it's also for you for
that well i'm sure if fedor looks in the
mirror he says i look damn good today
it's also a genetic factor some people
you know it's harder for them i mean
yeah